Apple CEO Tim Cook blasted Facebook over
the privacy of its users in the wake of
the data mining scandal he said
yesterday collecting information about
personal lives is an invasion of privacy
we could make a ton of money if we
monetized our customer if our customer
was our product we could make a ton of
money we've elected not to do that
privacy to us is a human right it's a
civil liberty for its part Facebook now
says it'll let users see the data it's
collected on them and delete it only to
copal is here with how that change may
come too late for many people don't get
more yeah too late indeed I took a trip
to Stanford University which is just a
few miles down the road from Facebook
headquarters but it's home to a data
scientist with a very different view of
the future of privacy no matter what
Facebook does now
he says don't expect to keep many
secrets considerably more intelligent
than average according to your digital
footprint getting my PhD at a mall near
Stanford University we gave shoppers the
chance to experience the kind of
Facebook data mining used by Cambridge
analytic a political consulting firm
they logged onto Facebook and linked to
a program that analyzes their profiles
to predict personality and more quite a
bit more spontaneous and impulsive you
value practical outcomes of overflight
imagination
the program is the work of Stanford
University data scientist Mahal
Kaczynski with consent from Facebook
users he and a colleague built and
studied an archive of more than eight
million profiles now he thinks the era
of privacy is over there's no going back
correct so the sooner we accept the fact
that we essentially lost our privacy
the sooner we can sit down and have a
very important conversation which is how
to make sure that this post privacy
world is still a safe and habitable
place to live
Kaczynski and colleagues have shown that
by using Facebook Likes alone their
model can predict personality better
than a person's friends family even
their spouse very accurate it's scary
because I feel like they can manipulate
certain things among the more unusual
correlations liking thunderstorms and
having higher intelligence liking hello
kitty and leaning toward democratic
politics and liking pop-tarts if you are
less satisfied with your life these are
some funny findings in this paper but
also there are very serious consequences
if other people know you very well it's
easier for them to convince you to do
things like vote for the candidates who
may not have your interests or your your
best interests at heart if somebody
wants to keep using Facebook but also
wants to be confident that they're not
being manipulated what can they do well
they should educate themselves we should
work on reducing our weaknesses and one
way of becoming stronger is knowing more
what would you tell other people about
what you saw today watch what you pose
trouble is Kaczynski says there is
already enough public data out there the
profile most of us with scary accuracy
for example he recently showed that
given just 5 online photos a computer
could correctly identify a person
sexuality so his message here is not get
off social media he sees benefits to it
but be aware be very aware of how you
can be exposed I'm very upset by this
pop-tart my whole outlook clearly they
haven't put it in a toaster by morning
really good
i mighta got you happy oh and it is you
happy it was very interesting to me to
go for